the question which we want to discuss
today is why do students have to study
so many subjects from engineering and
science once they enter an Institute
after the je counseling process despite
the fact that the student has already
been allocated a department
I'm sure this question has vexed many a
student's mind it has vexed me also for
a long time and this question was
actually posed by a student
named keshav goel from bits pilani he is
studying Electronics there through the
Google form which I had shared a few
weeks ago so thank you Kesha for sharing
this very important question for asking
this very important question let's
discuss this now so
what are the issues at stake here first
of all if the natural equation is if the
student has already been allocated a
department why study this broad base of
things the most common reason which is
given in favor of such a system is that
look engineering by its very nature is a
very interdependent uh professional work
which involves
Knowledge from various Fields so even if
a mechanical engineering is working in
something at a professional level in an
industry he needs to have some basic
understanding of electrical technology
about electronics and certainly
about some amount of computing besides a
host of other things from physics and
chemistry so that is the most common
reason but I personally think that this
kind of a reasoning is a little bit
flawed given the kind of intensity with
which we teach these subjects in the
first year look I am myself a faculty
member here in the mechanics reading
Department of IIT kharagpur and I have
very much been involved in the teaching
of first-year mechanics
and when we teach first-year mechanics
we certainly make it we certainly teach
it in a way which involves uh
very very specialized knowledge in
certain topics the kind of knowledge
that kind of specialist knowledge which
is perhaps not necessary for students
who are not from the mechanical Sciences
uh see for students who are from
mechanical certainly from civil
Aerospace or Aeronautics uh ocean engine
and Naval architecture to a certain
extent Mining and even Metallurgy the
way that we teach mechanics in first
year agreed it is absolutely
foundational
but what use really is it for a student
from computer science a student from
chemistry that is Highly Questionable so
you see I have very I myself been very
much part of the problem uh similarly
for a student who in in mechanical
engineering
now what use really is of him studying
an entire semester or perhaps an a
significant part of his semester
studying hardcore uh reaction mechanisms
that is taught as part of the organic
chemistry of first year chemistry that
is extremely
extreme specialized thing which these
students will never ever done so you see
the problem here and this is a very very
these these are all very personal
opinions from my side okay perhaps would
it not be better if instead of this kind
of a very specialized knowledge we we
give the broad base of uh of this
education from various departments in
engineering and science to all the
students irrespective of the department
but make it less specialized perhaps
make it more practical oriented which
will require a lot of investment of our
time and thinking on how to make it make
that knowledge uh relevant for
professional practice
let us consider another aspect of it
somebody May argue that look we have the
system here but it is not so much better
elsewhere for example in the U.S they
also have to study
a number of subjects in the first year
but there is a very important and subtle
difference actually not so subtle so see
when the undergraduate students
they start their curriculum and they
have actually entered the University or
The Institute but they have not actually
entered the department there
so in their first year and to a certain
extent even in their second year they
study subjects which are very general so
everyone is studying various kinds of
subjects and slowly slowly as they
develop their maturity their academic
maturity they develop their own
interests and very importantly they
realize their own strengths and
weaknesses based on those realizations
based on that understanding and greater
maturity it is only then that they get
into they that they choose their various
Majors they call it as Mages it's
actually just the department
so a student would be taking mechanical
engineering only if he thinks that he
can perform well in mechanical
engineering because once he enters this
enters the mechanical engineering system
that part that part of the curriculum he
has to do very hardcore courses there
similarly it is in computer science or
in any other of the other Majors so what
about another country let's take up the
case of the United Kingdom so two
pillars of the higher education system
of the United Kingdom are of course
Oxford University and Cambridge
University and uh
there at least for maths and physics
when you enter the University at that
very point you have to choose the
specialization of maths and physics
there are specialized entrance
examinations for maths and physics I I
think it's the same for chemistry also
so
a person a student who is entering Maths
for example
when he enters that he uh he or she has
to specialize in maths from Day Zero
there are no two words about it okay so
right from Day Zero he or she has
started doing courses in the maths
Department similarly in physics it's not
that he he goes about studying a broad
base of subjects so this is for the
Sciences what about engineering well for
engineering at Oxford and Cambridge they
have a slightly different system their
entire program is called the engineering
Sciences so when a student enters the
University
uh he or she is actually enrolled in
general engineering science
so in the first year and again to a
large extent in the second year
officially they are doing uh very well
designed General courses which are
supposed to train them in uh in gaining
a very wide base of knowledge in things
which every engineer is supposed to be
good at
it is
specialized where it needs to be
specialized it is kind of maybe less
rigorous where it needs to be so so it
is actually designed keeping in mind the
the general requirements of a
professional engineer
it is only after the second year that
the students start the specializations
into the different departments so we can
actually see the
undergraduate course listing here at
Oxford
the engineering you can it's clearly
written here the engineering science
program is a four-year course leading to
the degree of Master of engineering the
first two years are devoted to topics
that will that we believe all
engineering undergraduate students
should study so this is the very
important part okay they have designed
it in such a way
it is only in the third and fourth years
that there is scope for specialization
into one of the six branches of
engineering that they have okay so these
are the various things that they can
specialize in from their third year
and uh please don't worry that this is
master of engineering they have a
slightly different system of Bachelors
and Masters over there so this is kind
of equivalent to our b-tech courses this
is for uh Oxford this is for Cambridge
and here also you see it's clearly
written that part one the years one and
two provides a broad education in
engineering fundamentals enabling you to
make a genuinely informed choice about
the area in which to specialize from
your third year
Okay so
this year's three and four then provides
in-depth training in your chosen
professional discipline and these are
the specializations available so
Aerospace and Aero thermal engineering
bioengineering civil structure
environmental engineering so a host of
different things this was about Oxford
and Cambridge uh however the system is a
little bit different at Imperial so
Imperial is arguably one of the top
engineering programs uh certainly in the
UK
and uh
globally also
there for example if you have to study
mechanical engineering so right from the
admission you would be specializing in
mechanical engineering so starting from
year one you'd be studying courses uh
involving mechanics then stress analysis
fluid mechanics thermodynamics let's
take a look actually so this is a
mechanical engineering
in year one you have these basic courses
so the system is quite different from
Oxford and Cambridge and then in year
two you have a similar sounding
subjects but there is a two here so this
is slightly more advanced and then in
year three you have a very important
projects which they have to do very very
seriously and then you have a huge
number of optionals from which they can
choose similarly it is in year four also
you have projects very important
projects and then you have a number of
very Advanced options uh elective
subjects to choose from so the point
that I'm trying to make is that here in
India I think we have the basic kernel
of the proper system okay it's not all
bad certainly not okay ah but there is
certainly scope for improvement perhaps
we can incorporate a little bit more
flexibility in how the students can
choose their specializations I know a
big big question mark is that what will
happen to the department change system
then if you think about it if we have
such a flexibility right from the first
year where students don't have to choose
a department the question of Department
change would not even arise I know it is
it is not such a simple solution to to
the existing system and the problems
associated with it so these are some of
my personal feelings maybe after the J
if the student is not forced to take up
a department because Frankly Speaking he
or she doesn't know anything about any
Department I didn't know most of my
friends didn't know
so if they are not forced to take up a
department maybe they choose an
Institute uh then go to The Institute
study the courses in the first year
maybe the second year too uh at least
the first three semesters I think three
semesters is required I mean this is
this is just an arbitrary thought that I
have
and then maybe encourage them to take up
various kinds of departments and then
maybe uh I mean the advantage could be
that uh just compared to the GE rank
which is just a one disk performance
after that when the students come here
and they perform over the course of two
or three semesters that's a better
reflection of uh
of their potential the academic
potential their interests and how much
sustained efforts they can put in based
on that perhaps if even in a competitive
way the Departments can be allocated
perhaps it will be somewhat of a better
system than what we have currently
so these are just some thoughts I have
put out uh I know there are extreme
challenges to actually implementing them
just making a YouTube video is very easy
uh just saying these things is very easy
but actually implementing them is really
really difficult I know the challenges
but maybe some thought can be invested
in this direction so even as a faculty I
just want to say that for you students
ah if you are thinking like this You Are
Not Alone
uh many of us in the faculty positions
also feel this we have gone through the
process we know some of the
disadvantages that are there
but uh
one advice I would say is that you may
be listening to this video and then you
may be agreeing to it also
uh certainly keshift may be feeling very
happy about it uh
but
please do try to understand as long as
you're part of a system despite me
saying many of these things
it is not going to change overnight okay
when you are part of a system make
all-out effort to make the best of what
you have okay this many a time in your
life where you have to do the things
where which which are just there for you
okay you have to go through that process
so that later on you can do some of the
things which you really really want to
do
okay so with this thought I will wish
all of you the very best
see you next time bye